[Music]
let's go out to Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
and talk to Christopher what's up
Christopher hi Dr jalani thank you so
much for taking my call I appreciate it
you got it man what's
up
so I want to help my brother
out um he's fought a long hard battle
with
alcohol and I've just noticed recently
in the past several months it's just
gotten worse and worse and worse and he
hasn't hit a rock bottom Point yet but
several several members of our family
have tried to talk to him and it nothing
is getting through to him and I just I
hate seeing this happen to him and I
want to know how I can help him if if I
can yeah man he's uh he's lucky to have
you as his brother
man it's pretty pretty amazing do you
live in the same Community as him
uh we're two towns apart but you know
within about a 20 30 minute drive okay
great um what have people tried to do
how how's that conversation
gone I know my parents have talked to
him I I don't know what the conversation
was my unfortunately my side of the
family is not open communicators okay um
so I know they tried talking to him and
tried convincing him didn't get anywhere
um his wife tried bribing him after you
know talking several times she tried
bribing him by buying him a big present
if he stopped drinking and of course you
know that probably lasted a few days
yeah that doesn't work it doesn't work
oh man yeah and every every time I see
him now he's like slurring stumbling
yeah you know even in the middle of the
day okay so he's when you see him he's
actively
intoxicated yeah okay so here's a couple
of rules of thumb when I'm talking to
somebody who's struggling like this okay
um number one I can't make anyone listen
I can't make anyone do
anything and therefore I'm not
personally responsible for what choices
they
make right it's one of the scariest
hardest truths to
internalize
okay yep um hang on one second Kelly
have I asked talked on this show about
my dad and the SWAT stuff and listening
and
falling um I don't believe so okay Chris
I'm GNA give you a what is a very tragic
truth um but one that is something I
live by okay it was taught to me by my
dad my dad was a SWAT hostage negotiator
um and so one of his jobs when somebody
was way up on a building uh on top of
building there were going to jump okay
um he would go up the elevator in let's
say it's in a giant hotel he'd go up in
the elevator and he would get out of the
elevator by
himself and he would always take a knee
and he would
pray and then the question they would
ask himself is watch or
listen and the reason he would ask
himself that is he was prepping for if
this person decides to go and jump
despite his best
efforts and that simple question
provides a little bit of psychological
space that lets me operate without
knowing that I'm not Tethered to this
person does that make
sense yeah put some psychological
distance so you can have a more
objective view there you go because if
every time you see him you think it's
your job to save him you're going to end
up drowning
yourself so remembering and
internalizing I can't make him hear me I
can't make him do
anything he is making an adult Choice
okay so that's number one number two
there is no conversation to be had when
someone's intoxicated
period period the first 20 years of my
career I spent working with intoxicated
college students and I first would sit
there in their rooms with the police
officer and we'd have these long drone
out conversation by the time I'd been
doing it for 5 six seven years I
switched I would if they were safe I'd
tell them to go to bed if they were not
safe they would go to the hospital um if
they had broken the law they'd be
arrested and I would always tell them we
will meet tomorrow at 11:00
a.m. because you can't you can't hear a
word I'm saying right
now right right so that's
that's number two they you can tell
y'all can have the most heartfelt
beautiful souls connecting
conversation but if they're not sober
that conversation's not getting through
yeah short for memory shot right it's
just just everything right yeah so
here's what you can do oh here's the
third thing when somebody is this this
struggling this deeply with
alcohol I don't want to ask the question
why won't you quit
drinking I want to ask asked the
question what in the world happened in
your life and is continuing to happen
that this is the best way your body has
figured out how to get through a
day because that answer is
where the solution
lies okay it humanizes a person in front
of you as you're watching them just
struggle
right so here's what you can give him
you can give him an environment and a
Rel relationship where he is able to
listen if he chooses
to so what does that look
like if this was my brother I would do
two things I would write a short and
very clear and simple letter that begins
with dear brother I love
you and what I'm hoping is in a moment
when he wakes up and he's sober and his
body feels like absolute run over by a
truck tell and before he reaches for a
bottle he's able to read dear brother I
love
you
okay the next part of that letter would
be something along the lines
of when you're ready to be well when
you're ready to get help I am here and I
will go to the ends of the Earth I will
run through hell for my
brother and it's short and it's sweet
and it's very very
clear and then I would be about inviting
him out hey do you want to come have
breakfast with me I'll only have it if
you're sober if you're not sober then
I'm not gonna I'm not going to do it so
you get to choose but I really want to
go to breakfast with
you I had thought of trying to get him
to a neutral place like a coffee shop
that's right you know in the morning
when he's hopefully not started yet and
you know have that conversation with do
you think it would make sense to deliver
the letter at that point absolutely yes
okay and I would tell him maybe with a
smile on your
face I felt like I needed to write my
brother a love letter and let you know
that I love you and if you don't say
that in your family sounds like you have
a family that doesn't share their
feelings and emotions very often this
might be super awkward yeah it will be
and I think you plow right through that
awkwardness and look him dead in his
eyes and say I'm your brother and I love
you okay okay can can I throw a wrench
in it wrench it all
up I fought the same battle for years
okay are you sober
now no okay I I was for last winter okay
um that fell off the fell off the rails
over uh last spring and uh I'm ready to
jump back on a gun awesome so
so so conversation feels a little bit
uh you know to faced you know not at all
I want to help you while I'm still
fighting the side battle no man in fact
in a strange way it gives you um a
little bit of uh empathy and
credibility I'm going to a meeting
tomorrow and I'd like to pick you up and
take
you and you can look across the table
because both of y'all went through it
when y'all were little didn't you
yeah we both started early school that's
right because you had
to and we don't talk about this enough
in the addiction communities but the
alcohol worked it kept you two alive
didn't
it in a weird sort of way I guess that's
right it worked and now it's got you and
that's it's time to
stop
I realized at one point that I had gone
from Recreation to medication and that's
what I knew I had to do something about
it when you're drinking as a young kid
and your brother is too it's always been
medication just the medication stop
being
fun it's always been medication and for
whatever happened dude I'm so sorry that
y'all had to live like
that and I'm
I'm I'm other planetary proud of
you for saying enough is enough I'm
done thank you it's
hard and good god dude you're doing it
in the black hole of a Pittsburgh winter
for crying out
loud I'm gonna get sober with no sun
good job Chris good
job but I think there's something
powerful about writing your brother Love
Letter here's the other thing there's
something powerful about writing
14-year-old Christopher a love letter
too because that kid's life has been
tough It's had its
challenges that's the most I struggle
with addiction thing I've heard all
day I'm I'm happy that I've been
blessed that I've never hit rock
bottom and nothing serious has ever
happened because of my drinking but I
know I've burned
relationships and lost time and I just
want it to be in my rearview here we
talk a lot about Rock Bottom
dude
but there is rock bottom and if you've
ever been have you been to meetings
before yeah yeah you hear you hear the
atomic Rock bottoms that happens but
dude I I just don't think most people
make the transition out of Rock
Bottom I think for most people Rock
Bottom is they live underwater in their
own
life their whole life is lived under a
mattress like Fight Club it's just a
copy of a copy of a copy nothing tastes
good nothing the sleep isn't good sex
isn't good marriage isn't good it just
is and you just deserve so much freaking
more than
that there's so much Beauty in the world
and everything doesn't have to be shades
of brown and
gray and so there is this big rock
bottom I'm glad you're not in jail I'm
glad you're not dead I'm glad you didn't
wreck a car or kill somebody of course
but man I'm equally
heartbroken that you wake up up every
day and you look at your watch and you
think 12 more hours I can climb back
into this bed and call
it that's not quite that bad I
know but the the whole you know every
evening you know crack the first one
open crack the second one open and
continue
until know I end up finally falling
asleep it's just that's right I can't do
it anymore that's right and I'm proud of
you for this
moment I'm proud of
you now you got to make the next right
step as they
say but I think there's something
powerful about telling your brother hey
me too and I love you and I'm going to a
meeting tomorrow because I have to be I
have to be done and that means I'm gonna
have to face My Demons head
on and I'd love you to be sitting right
shoulder-to-shoulder with me facing him
too
and if you won't go just give him the
letter and let him know that I'm there
when he's ready whenever you're ready
I'm
here
yeah then you're GNA walk the you're
going to walk the walk
right yeah or walk the talk I guess is
what they
say will you call me in 30 days when you
get your chip
I
will yes I will if you call me a 30 days
and give me a chip I'm going to make a a
monetary donation to a local Addiction
Center in my community on your with your
name on it okay that' be awesome thank
you and I'll carry that all the way
through until you get one year chip
that's my commitment to
you I appreciate that Dr John thank you
you in are you
in yeah right
okay I'm proud of you brother hang on
the line um Jenna's going to hook you up
with
um a couple of different things she's
going to hook you up with both of my
books she's going to hook you up with um
I don't know many people who are
wrestling with um addiction who aren't
also do also have chaotic Financial
lives and I happened to just work at
Ramy Solutions where they help people
get out of debt so I'm going to hook you
up with the financial piece series for
free and and the every dollar app that
will help you make a budget and begin to
get some control back in your life
there's something about leaving your
first uh your first 12-step meeting and
there's that relief and then there's
that oh God I got to face the music well
I want you to have tools in your hand to
face the music okay so I'm going to hook
you up with that stuff as well so hang
on the line here and Jenna will get you
taken care of I'm proud of you today
this is your Independence Day this is
your day of where you of Freedom where
you begin solving and choosing Freedom
I'm proud of you my brother
I look forward to hearing from you in 30
days